CONGRESSWOMAN ILHAN OMAR SAYING
IT WOULD BE APPALLING TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE DEAL WITH NO
STRINGS ATTACHED.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS NOT
COMMENTING.
ANTHONY.
>> THANK YOU.
>>> THE CORONAVIRUS VACCINES ARE
MAKING A HUGE DIFFERENCE FOR THE
FIRST TIME SINCE THE PANDEMIC
BEGAN THE NUMBER OF NEW CASES IS
DOWN IN ALL 50 STATES.
THAT'S AFTER 154 MILLION ADULTS
IN AMERICA HAVE HAD AT LEAST ONE
DOSE WHICH IS NEARLY 60%.
NATIONWIDE, NEW CASES ARE DOWN
87% SINCE JANUARY.
DEATHS HAVE PLUNGED A REMARKABLE
82%.
MOLA LENGHI IS IN BROOKLYN WERE
PREINSTRUCTIONS ARE STARTING TO
EASE.
MOLA, GOOD MORNING.
>> Reporter: GOOD MORNING,
ANTHONY, NEW YORK STATE AND THE
REST OF THE STATE BEGINNING
TOMORROW WILL GET BACK TO NORMAL
AT LEAST CLOSE TO NORMAL AS
WE'VE SEEN DURING THE ENTIRE
PANDEMIC.
COURSE MORE THAN A YEAR NOW,
STARTING WEDNESDAY, MASK
RESTRICTIONS WILL BE LIFTED FOR
VACCINATED PEOPLE IN NEW YORK
WITH SOME EXCEPTIONS LIKE
HOSPITALS AND PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION.
NOW, WITH THAT SAID, MASK
MANDATES ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE
ANYTHING BUT UNIFORM, MIRRORING
THE PATCHWORK OF RULES THAT
REALLY USHERED IN THE PANDEMIC.
NEW YORK AND CALIFORNIA HAVE
ALMOST THE SAME VACCINATION
RATE, BUT CALIFORNIA IS KEEPING
ITS MASK MANDATE FOR AT LEAST
ANOTHER MONTH.
BACK HERE IN THE NORTHEAST, NEW
JERSEY STILL REQUIRES MASKS
INDOORS.
AND WHILE PENNSYLVANIA HAS EASED
ITS RESTRICTIONS, THE CITY OF
PHILADELPHIA HAS NOT.
IT'S NOT JUST STATES.
MAJOR CORPORATIONS ARE ALSO
EASING THEIR COVID RESTRICTIONS,
TARGET, CVS, STARBUCKS ARE JUST
THE LATEST COMPANIES TO DROP
MASK REQUIREMENTS FOR VACCINATED
CUSTOMERS IN THEIR STORES AROUND
THE COUNTRY.
ON THE OTHER HAND, THE KROGER
GROCERY CHAIN IS KEEPING ITS
MASK MANDATE.
NOW, WITH ALL OF THESE STATES,
CITIES AND COMPANIES TAKING
DIFFERENT APPROACHES TO MASK TO
CAN IMAGINE IT'S CAUSING
CONFUSION.
BUT THE WHITE HOUSE CAME OUT